bonjour c'est Bruno posé j'ai 48 ans et
j'ai deux enfants et je suis véculé je
possède le permis B je suis actuellement
à la recherche d'un emploi comme
mécanicien dans un garage tout
simplement j'habite à 5 outils je
souhaiterais travailler depuis tout dans
la région Nord dans mon dernier emploi
j'ai suivi plusieurs formations véhicule
hybride véhicule diesel et je possède un
agrément climatisation j'ai travaillé 32
ans de mécanique dans plusieurs garages
Macao garagiste
passons-nous automobile et je suis un
ancien préparateur de voiture de rallye
j'ai suivi Jean-Claude salé
William Madara si vous êtes intéressé
par mon profil contactez-moi